[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: All right, folks.
I think it's about
time to get started.
Thank you guys for making
it to our problem session
and I guess talking
to many of you guys
virtually, given the number
of people in the room.
But that's perfectly fine.
Right.
So we're in problem session
number two for 6.006.
Hopefully you're all
in the right place.
I'm Justin.
I was looking at a little
spreadsheet of who's
teaching what, and I think
you guys are stuck with me
in a lot of these problem
sessions, which actually, I
think in terms of
hours of video,
means that you're stuck
listening to my voice the most.
So sorry in advance.
But in any event, it's always
fun to do this kind of thing.
And it gave me the opportunity
to do homework, which I have
not done in a very long time.
So last night, I worked through
all these problems and came up
with my own hacked-together
answers for these,
which thankfully more or
less agreed with what was
in the answer key, which
I have and you don't.
I think that we release on--
so there's a bit of
a known bug in 6.006,
which is that this instructor
has horrible handwriting.
I'm working on it.
I went to the classroom and
practiced the other day.
But in the meantime, there
are horrible handwritten notes
that are posted in the
learning module, at least
for the duration
of the talk today.
And we'll decide whether
we want to leave them
up or not because they're
not super exciting.
Just so you can make sure you
can follow along with that,
I'm writing on the board.
And as with before, if
there's ever anything
that you can't
read, just stop me.
And I'll gladly fix.
Cool.
So right, so hopefully,
does everybody
have a copy of the problems?
It'll look a little
different from this.
The green stuff is the answers.
I get those, and you don't.
Or sorry, I always ask this
question when I'm teaching,
and you never get an answer.
Does anybody not have a copy
of the problems and the problem
session?
Fabulous.
OK.
If you don't, there's a
pile of handouts up here.
Here, I'll grab one for you.
Yeah.
Great.
So the basic goal of
the problem sessions
is to go over a bunch of example
problems, which I believe
are mostly lifted from past
years' homeworks and exams,
and work through how
we went about thinking
about them and a solution or
at least just kind of sketch
out enough that we're
confident you could fill
in the blanks of
a solution, given
our limited time together.
Right.
And of course, one
of the pleasures
of teaching this problem
session is this is not normally
the class that I teach.
So these really are problems
I haven't seen before.
And indeed, in the
middle of the night
last night, I woke
up and realized
my answer to the last
problem was totally wrong.
So if you feel
that way sometimes,
the feeling is mutual.
So in any event, there are
four problems on your handout
that roughly, I think,
are in correspondence
with the stuff we've taught
over the last week or so.
So the first problem
involves recurrences.
The second involves
Infinity Stones.
The third involves some kind
of a queue stack structure.
And the fourth
involves all kinds
of things talking to each other
in a way that I got wrong.
So I guess for lack of
a more creative thing,
we'll just go through
these guys in order.
And essentially,
this is supposed
to be an interactive session,
although it doesn't really
look that way.
But since you guys are
the people in the room,
you have the advantage of being
able to stop me the second
that I, A, make a
mistake or, B, say
something that confuses you.
And I'm relying on
you to do that, OK?
Nods.
That's our deal today.
Some kind of acknowledgment.
Noses out of the laptops,
maybe, for a second.
Cool.
Thank you.
See, thumbs up.
That's what I'm looking for.
OK.
All right, folks.
Right, so let's start with
the problem number one here.
So problem number one
is solving recurrences,
which is our favorite
way to torture
undergrads in algorithms classes
in the first couple of weeks.
And in particular, applying
this master theorem.
So I thought I'd spent about
82 seconds reviewing master
theorem because this is sort
of the giant sledgehammer
for solving recurrences
without understanding why you
got the answer that you did.
And then for each
of these problems,
conveniently, this
homework problem
asks you to do each big
O thing twice, right?
Once using master theorem
to kind of get you
used to just applying
this little set of rules,
which is sort of the
most efficient way
to solve recurrences.
It just gives you a
formula to look at.
In addition to that, drawing
a tree of computation
and counting the number
of computations you do.
So the first two are basically
straightforward applications
of master theorem.
The third one requires a
little bit of thinking.
So naturally, I got stuck
and wasted an hour yesterday
trying to convince myself
the answer was right.
OK.
So for a tiny bit of
review, I know that you also
did this in recitation.
But it can't hurt to
bring it up again.
Remember that master theorem--
I believe that "master" really
is just because it's general,
right?
There's not a guy
named Master, but I
notice that it was capitalized
a lot in the course notes.
But in any event,
the basic idea is
that it has some
recurrence that looks
like the following, which
is T of n equals aT of n/b
plus f of n.
So for instance, in merge
sort, for a tiny bit of review,
remember that we kind of
split into two pieces.
So both a and b in
merge sort would be 2.
Yeah.
And the amount of work
that I do in the merge step
is kind of like n.
So that's how to fill in these
different constants there.
And the question
is, asymptotically,
what does this
function look like?
And of course, it's not totally
obvious from this formula
because I've defined T in
terms of itself, right?
And that's the sort of annoying
part of solving recurrences.
And so master theorem, and
I'll let you guys review
your section notes about
precisely how this gets proved,
essentially divides
into three cases.
And the relevant numbers
here are as follows, right?
There's an a, a b, and an f.
And so the a is kind of like
a branching factor, right?
So if you remember
your computation tree,
like in merge sort, you
split into two pieces, right?
So that number is
kind of like a.
It's the number of splits
that you make, right?
b is the amount that your
problem size reduces when
you go to each of those leaves.
And then finally, f
is the amount of work
that you do at each node.
Yeah, so hopefully that
basic language makes sense.
And then essentially what
you learn from master theorem
is that there's three cases.
The first is that
f of n looks like--
by the way, in the recitation
notes, for some reason,
it's kind of written backward.
They give the answer to master
theorem and then the condition.
I'm going to write
in the other order.
Right.
Looks like the following,
which is n to the log
base b of a minus epsilon
for some positive epsilon.
I'm going to try to be very
conscientious about reading
my writing out loud
as I write it down.
All right.
And in that case,
what we find is notice
there's something
kind of magic here,
which is that this is
just an upper bound.
There's not a theta here.
So it's OK if f is
below this thing.
But in any event, the
conclusion then is that T of n
is big theta of n to
the log base b of a.
It's kind of cool if
you think about it.
You only have an
upper bound for f,
but you get a nice theta bound
for T, which is pretty cool.
The reason for that
is essentially the f
is sort of insignificant
relative to the work
of just traversing
up and down the tree.
That's case one.
Case two-- I'm going to try and
leave this on the board as we
actually solve these problems--
is the following,
which is f of n
is big theta of
n to the log base
b of a multiplied by log
to the k-th power of n.
This is a super weird
form, but for example, it's
perfectly kosher to take
k equals 0, in which case
it starts to look
like case one, right?
For some positive k or
non-negative k, rather,
in which case what we
learn is that T of n
is theta of n to the log base
b of a times log to the k
plus 1 of n.
You can see why we don't
love applying this theorem
in this course
because I feel just
staring at these formulas
is totally unenlightening.
But it is a giant sledgehammer
for solving recurrences
quickly.
And then finally, case three--
I'm going to slide
the board up, and I'm
going to slide it
back down because I
don't want to bend over.
OK-- is the following, which
is f of n is omega, right,
meaning that it's lower
bounded by n to the log base
b of a plus epsilon for
some epsilon greater than 0.
And we needed a second case.
What's it called? af of
n over b is less than cfn
for some c between 0 and 1.
And what's the conclusion there?
Then it turns out that the
f term sort of dominates,
and what we get is that T
of n is theta of f of n.
OK.
So essentially, this
covers three major cases
that you see in recurrences.
There are other more generic
versions of the master theorem
out there where essentially,
rather than just
having one term with the T in
it, maybe use more than one
term with a T in it.
I don't think those are
covered in this class.
I always confuse the name
of the more general one.
I want to say it's
Arzela-Ascoli,
but I know that that's
from functional analysis.
[INAUDIBLE] theorem, if you
want to Google that, learn more.
But in any event, that's
going to be enough for most
of the recurrences
we care about in 006.
So I've at least written
our conditions down.
And now they're going to
sit on the left-hand side
while we do three
example problems to show
how they show up in practice.
Are there any questions about
what this theorem is telling us
about life or how to apply it?
Don't all speak at once now.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I have
a handwriting question.
PROFESSOR: No problem.
AUDIENCE: What's after
"some," the last line?
PROFESSOR: Oh, for some
c in 0, 1, not inclusive.
Fabulous question.
Any others?
OK.
So let's do an
example problem here.
So let's do part a.
So in part a, they
give you a recurrence,
which isn't all that
different from merge
sort or any of the other ones.
It looks something like this.
T of n is equal to
2T of n/2 plus--
and then they have some other
term, which they don't tell you
anything about beyond that
it's big O of square root of n.
By the way, this might
mean that it actually
does order 1 work, right?
It just has to be upper
bounded by a square root of n.
That's the only thing that
problem's telling you.
I'm going to keep
kind of driving home
that point because I think
everybody, including myself,
gets really sloppy about,
like, when is it O?
When is it theta?
When's it omega?
And so every single time you
write one of those letters
down, you should step back
50 feet and look at it
and think, like,
did I do that right?
Or did I just write a
Greek letter, right?
And make sure that
you're actually
thinking through it logically.
OK.
So when I apply master theorem
in my everyday life, what
I like to do is to
say, OK, somehow,
the really key quantity
in master theorem
is this dude, right, n
to the log base b of a.
He just keeps showing up in
all these different cases.
So I might as well figure what
that is for my recurrence,
yeah, and then plug it in
and check which case I'm in.
Does that make sense?
So let's do that.
So first of all, what is a for
this particular recurrence?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: 2.
What's b?
You're killing me, guys.
On 3.
1, 2, 3.
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: OK.
The enthusiasm is overwhelming.
OK, and what do we know
about the function f?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's big O of root n.
We don't know that
it equals root n.
But we do know that it's at
most upper bounded by something
that kind of looks like root n.
Eric gave me a whole
lesson on this chalk,
and I'm still failing at it.
OK.
So now that gives us
everything we need to compute n
to the log base b of a.
We're going to do
this one real slowly,
and then we're going to do the
next one a little more fastly,
quickly.
So n to the log base b of a.
Well, that's n to
the log base 2 of 2.
Anybody have an idea?
What's the log base 2 of 2?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
OK, I'll take it this time.
OK.
Right.
And so then what does
master theorem tell you?
Well, in some sense,
I want to know
what f is, which in this case
looks like square root of n,
compared to what this
is, n to the first.
Yeah?
Now, first of all, which of
these two things grows faster?
This guy, right?
So what we know is that f is
really upper bounded by this n
here.
"Upper bounded" is not
quite the right term
because big O allows
for some wiggle room,
but asymptotically.
Hopefully you guys
get this concept.
OK, so in particular, let's see.
So remember that f of--
let's maybe just write it again.
So f of n is big O
of square root of n.
But let's write that in a
suggestive way as n to the 1/2.
Yeah.
In particular, this is equal to
big O of n to the 1 minus 1/2.
It's the beautiful
thing about 1/2.
Yeah.
But what is n to the 1?
Well, that's n to the
log base b of a, right?
That's what we just
showed here, right?
So this is really
O of n to the log b
of a-- that's a complicated
way of writing the number 1,
right--
minus 1/2.
Let's give 1/2 a special
name, too, while we're at it.
Let's call him
epsilon or her, yeah,
where we take epsilon equals--
see what I did there?
Now, what does it tell me?
There are three different
cases of master theorem.
And take a look at
what I just showed.
I showed that f of n is equal
to big O of n to the log base
b of a minus epsilon for some
epsilon that's equal to 1/2.
The beautiful thing about 1/2
is that it is greater than 0.
Yeah.
So I think we have somewhat
laboriously checked
that we are in case one.
Any dissidents here?
Fabulous.
OK.
So in that case, master
theorem, basically,
you're just done, right?
So what is the conclusion?
AUDIENCE: T of n is theta of n.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So T of n is theta of n
to the log base b of a.
But we already showed
that's equal to n.
So we're done.
All right.
Any questions about how we
apply master theorem here?
OK.
So now here's the thing
about master theorem.
Did we learn anything about
what this recursive function
is doing?
No, we just did a bunch of work,
plugged in some Greek symbols,
and out came a big theta.
Yeah.
So what we might
want to do instead
is to use a method that
I'm still learning myself
because I'm not used to
presenting it this way,
but that's OK, which
is to actually draw out
the tree of computation.
Yeah.
So let's actually do that.
So let's say that I
call my function T of n.
So what does T of n do?
Well, in some sense, it
does work that kind of looks
like the square
root of n, right,
and then it makes two
function calls, each of which
has n/2 amount of data.
Yeah.
So let's draw what
this looks like.
So the first thing that
my function might do
is work square root of n much.
Going to put a little
square root of n there.
And now it makes
two function calls.
And how much work does
each of these guys do?
So when it calls T,
what goes into T?
n/2.
AUDIENCE: So square root of n/2.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So it does square root
of n/2 amount of work
at each of these two nodes.
That make sense?
AUDIENCE: That's determined by
the branching number, right?
PROFESSOR: You
have to be careful.
So the branching
number, in this case,
it happened to be the same.
The next problem we do,
they'll be different.
So they're both 2 here.
The outside 2 refers to the
fact that there's two children.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, never mind.
PROFESSOR: And inside
2 refers to the fact
that I divided by 2.
It's a fabulous question because
it's exactly what I got wrong
when I did this problem.
OK.
So now each of these guys
calls one of their children.
Yeah.
And so again, the
data divides by 2.
So now I have the square
root of n/4, like this.
Yeah.
If you're wondering, inside
of each of these circles,
it says square root of n/4.
OK.
So let's say that--
so now meanwhile, in our
function call tree here,
how many nodes are in just the
first level at the very top?
One, right?
Just this dude.
Yeah.
One node.
How many nodes are
in the second level?
Two.
Or if we want, 2 to the 1 nodes.
Here, there's four, yeah, which
is 2 squared nodes, and so on.
OK.
So now we have some
pictorial representation
of what's going on
inside of our recurrence.
If you look at the
course notes I wrote out,
I wrote out one more layer
just for fun and profit.
So now let's see how
this helps us actually
solve our recurrence.
So what do we know?
How many levels
are in this tree?
Well, our algorithm kind of
stops when the input to T
looks like 1, right?
So since this divides
by 2 each time,
the tree has log base 2
of n levels in the tree.
Yeah.
And each level
does how much work?
So be careful.
So each level-- let's
call that level l, right?
So we'll say l equals 0,
l equals 1, and so on.
So there's two
different things we
have to account
for when we account
for the work in this level.
One is the square root
of n/2 in a single node.
And the other is the fact that
there's two different nodes
in the level.
So in level l, so the
amount of work in level
l is equal to the product
of those two things.
So how many nodes
are in level l?
2 to the l, yeah?
OK.
And how much work does
each one of those nodes do?
It's like n/2 to the l.
So a different way
of writing that
is the square root of n times
2 to the minus l, like that.
This is just n/2 to the l.
Fabulous.
So now we have everything
we need to actually work out
our solution to the recurrence.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What does that say?
PROFESSOR: This is n
times 2 to the minus l.
I appreciate the [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to work on this more.
And that's why I
also share it online.
The handwritten notes is--
this is literally
a scan of the page
that I'm holding in front of me.
OK.
So if we want the total
amount of work in our tree,
right, if we want to account
for all of T of n, then what
are we going to do?
Well, we have to sum
starting at level 0.
I'm using l instead of i
because I'm an analysis person,
and i is the square
root of minus 1.
And I don't like i's
in my algorithms.
But in any event, how many total
levels are there in my tree?
Well, we know that there's
log base 2 of n, right?
And now we have to sum this
quantity for all those levels.
2 to the l, the square root
of n times 2 to the minus l,
like that.
OK.
And then what do we know
secretly from the master
theorem is that we're
suspecting that this is
going to be theta of n, right?
So that's all
we've got to check.
OK, so let's do that real fast.
So first of all,
notice that this n term
doesn't depend on the summand.
So I can just pull
them out, right?
So this is really the square
root of n times the sum over l
equals 0 to the
log 2 of n of what?
Oh, and there's a
mistake in my notes.
Oh, man.
Oh, no, this is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, right, duh.
OK.
So you have 2 to the l, and
you have a square root of 2
to the minus l.
So this is really
2 to the minus l/2.
So you have l minus l/2.
And this quantity is really
2 to the l/2, like that.
Does that make sense?
So this is just properties
of exponents from high school
class.
And in fact, I don't like
this because it's l/2,
and I want to blindly
apply a formula
without thinking about it.
And so of course, this
is really the same
as the square root of
2 to the l-th power.
This is just properties
of exponents.
OK.
So what is this sum called?
Do you recognize this?
So there's some constant here.
You're taking it
to the l-th power,
and then you're
summing it over l's.
This is called a
geometric series, right?
So it would be like 1
plus x plus x squared
plus x to the third
and dot dot dot, x
to the, I guess in this
case, log base 2 of n.
Yeah?
So conveniently, there's a
geometrics series formula
out there.
I wrote it down in
the handwritten notes,
but maybe for now, because
I'm moving slowly as always,
so we'll skip that part.
And what you could
is as follows,
that this is the square
root of n, right--
that's just this outer part--
times-- and the inside are going
to get the square root of 2
to the log base 2
of n plus 1 minus 1
divided by the square
root of 2 minus 1.
And this is the
geometric series formula.
So I encourage you guys to go
back home and Google that one
if you forgot.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Wait, why
are we calculating
the sum of the series?
PROFESSOR: Because
what we're trying
to do is figure out the total
amount of work in this tree,
right?
So what we've done
so far, we know
that a single level in
this tree is this value.
And now we have to sum
over all the levels from 0
to log base 2 of n.
AUDIENCE: OK, and what do
we use this number for?
PROFESSOR: Because we're
trying to actually approximate
or at least bound T of n, right?
And T of n is the sum
of all these values.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
And theta of n is not
a sufficient bound.
PROFESSOR: It is a
sufficient bound.
We just got it from
kind of a boring way.
This is a second
way that we could
have proved the same formula.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I see a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Can you go over
the root n, 2 minus l part?
I understand the 2 to
the l is the number
of nodes second part.
Does that work?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
OK, this is the number of nodes.
This is the quantity
inside of the circle.
So notice that it's
square root of n
and then square root of n/2
and then square root of n/4
and then square
root of n/8, right?
So 2 to the minus l here is like
1/2 and then 1/4 and then 1/8.
Yeah.
Fabulous.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if we
have log base 2n levels
and we started indexing
at 0, doesn't it
go from l equals 0 to
l equals 2n minus 1?
PROFESSOR: Oh, boy.
I'm bad at this stuff.
No, right?
I think this is correct.
Let's see.
So let's say that I
have n equals 2, right?
Then what's going to happen?
Yeah, no, this is correct.
So as a sanity check,
think about n equals 2.
So how many levels should it be?
It should go from l equals
0 and then l equals 1.
Then I'm done because I have T.
And then I think--
yeah, so the log
base 2 of 2 is 1.
So yeah, this
formula checks out.
OK, any other questions?
These are all great questions.
You guys are keeping me honest.
OK.
So we have this giant
ugly expression here.
And so our final job here
is just to simplify it.
That's it.
And then what we're going to
find is that this is secretly
just theta of n.
A little surprising, given
that this is kind of ugly.
OK.
And by the way, this
was just the constants.
So this term on the
denominator is not
going to end up mattering for
our asymptotic calculation.
OK.
Cool.
So let's see here.
So remember that the square
root of 2 is 2 to the 1/2.
Yeah.
So I can do a little bit of
reshuffling on our formula.
And what I'm going to find
is that this is exactly
the square root of n times
1 over the square root
of 2 minus 1.
That's just this constant here.
Now I just have to cope with
this funny term inside of here.
I'm going to do the following.
I'm going to say, well, square
root of 2 is the same as 2
to the 1/2.
So I'm going to write this by
moving that 1/2 upstairs here,
right?
So what am I going to get at
the end of the day is that this
is the same as 2 to the log base
2 of n plus 1 and all of that--
oops, plus 1/2, right, because
there's the 1/2 exponent that
got multiplied by the 1--
minus 1.
So this is just an identical
expression to this one.
All I've done is move
the 1/2 upstairs.
And finally, now there's
some order in the universe,
because what is 2 to
the log base 2 of n?
AUDIENCE: n.
PROFESSOR: n, exactly.
That's a very complicated
way of writing n.
So this is equal to the
square root of n times
1 over the square
root of 2 minus 1,
which is just a constant.
I see your hand.
I'm going to write, and
then I'll catch up with you.
And now this whole quantity is
n times the square root of 2,
right?
Oops, wait.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
That should be--
right, because we
moved the 1/2 into the exponent,
and I didn't account for it.
So this is the square
root of n multiplied
by the square root of 2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It'd be n/2
to the square root of n.
PROFESSOR: n/2 to
the square root of n.
No, I think this is right.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You guys are making me nervous.
OK, so finally, now we can
start to see the big O come out,
right?
Because now we have the
square root of n times itself
plus some other stuff, which is
obviously going to grow slower
than the remaining terms here.
So we're good.
If you're wondering,
the official solutions
are actually incorrect.
They, too, get this
a little bit wrong.
I'm going to fix that
tonight, and then we'll
post them for you guys.
And this unfortunately
is the kind of thing
you do a lot of, where you're
going to take your tree.
You write down this
giant tree formula here.
You write down a geometric
series of some sort
and then start bounding
terms until you
get to the expression you want.
So now you can see why
master theorem maybe
is kind of valuable because it
saves you a lot of headache.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When we
write up our piece sets
and we have to write
up trees like this,
can we hand draw them
and take pictures?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
don't see why not.
They don't have to draw
it in Dixie or something.
AUDIENCE: You can take
pictures of diagrams
as long as the math
doesn't [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think if you're just
writing out your math,
taking a photo of it, and
then, like, backslash include
graphics of your photo-- yeah.
But just for the figure,
I think that's fine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
In fact, when I write
research papers,
that's how I do it
until the final draft.
Yeah.
OK.
So essentially,
what did we just do
in this problem, which
is part a of one problem,
is essentially just showed
two different ways of solving
recurrence, right?
One is the sledgehammer
that's very efficient but not
terribly illustrative.
The other is really
working out all
of the work that happens
at every level of our tree,
doing a giant sum,
and then just actually
deriving the proper formula.
And both of these are
just different ways
to skin the same cat.
Is that a weird phrase?
I don't know.
OK.
So right, so actually,
part two, I believe,
ends up being easier
by a funny fluke
even though it looks
like it's harder.
So let's do that next here.
So I'm going to leave master
theorem on the left-hand side.
I really want to say
"master's theorem,"
but I guess that's not right.
I'm going to leave the master
theorem on the left-hand side.
Just do the problem over here.
I'm going to do this one a
little bit quicker because I
prefer not to spend the
whole session on one problem.
OK.
But I do think it's worth
spending a few minutes going
over this theorem and
how to apply it carefully
because, well,
otherwise, you won't.
OK.
All right, folks.
It's a workout up here.
So in part b, we
have a version where
the branching factor and the
amount that the work reduces
are not the same.
So now we have to be a little
bit more careful in the way
that we apply master
theorem, right?
So now in part b,
we have that T of n
here is equal to
8T of n/4 plus--
and now in the problem,
they write big O of n times
the square root of n.
We're all grown-ups here.
That's the same as
big O of n to the 3/2.
Yeah.
That's just arithmetic.
OK.
So first, let's apply
the master theorem.
Let's see.
So what is n to the log
base b of a, in this case?
Well, what is b?
4.
What is a?
8.
Anybody know log base 4 of 8?
AUDIENCE: 3/2.
PROFESSOR: Wow, you're good.
Yeah, so this is
equal to n to the 3/2.
And notice that these
two things agree now.
Yeah.
So which of the three cases of
the master theorem are we in?
Are we in the first one, where
one of these kind of dwarfs the
other?
No.
We're in case two, right,
where they both kind of
behave similarly.
Yeah.
So this is case two.
And what is the value of k for
case two that's relevant here?
Do I need a log factor?
No, these two terms are
just the same, right?
They're both n to the 3/2.
So this is case two
with k equals 0.
And in particular, immediately,
we get that T of n is--
let's see.
We're in case two, so we have
theta of n to the log base
b of a times log to
the k plus 1 of n.
So you have to account for
that term, so it's like that.
That make sense, how we applied
master theorem in that case?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how can we apply
case two if it's big O and not
big theta?
PROFESSOR: How can we
apply case two if f of n
is big O and not big theta?
Well, that's coming
from a grad student.
So why don't I ping it back
to the students in the class
rather than answering myself?
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So let's say that we
just have a big O. We
don't have a big theta here.
Or at least a simple answer,
which maybe is the one
that you're looking for.
So what do we know?
In that case, we
know that f of n
might grow more slowly
than this function.
But it doesn't grow more
quickly than this thing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would T of n just
be big O instead of big theta?
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
So you can just replace
big theta with big O,
and that's perfectly fine.
So I don't know if that's the
answer you're looking for.
But at least you get a
loose bound this way.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You should probably
write it big O in the answer
then.
PROFESSOR: Oops.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I see.
We're being pedantic.
OK.
You can just tell me
if I made a mistake.
It happens.
I think it's
correct in my notes.
It is.
OK.
So the reason our colleague
brings it up in the back
is that I made a
slight mistake, which
is that this is a big O,
not a big theta, right?
In which case, the only
thing I can draw down here
is that this is
also a big O. So I
made exactly the mistake I
told you guys to avoid before.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So then over there,
would those also be big O?
PROFESSOR: No.
Yeah, now I've managed
to confuse you.
This is correct.
This entire statement
of the master theorem,
assuming I copied it
correctly, is right.
But there's a bit
of a difference.
Remember, we wanted
to apply case two.
And look at case two.
So there's a theta here.
But in the problem, in
the homework problem,
they were sneaky.
And they only said that f
of T is big O of something.
So remember, what's
the difference
between big O and big theta?
Well, intuitively, big theta
says that my function really
does look like this guy.
Somehow, it's bounded above and
below as I go far enough out.
In big O, there's just
a bound above, right?
So this is somehow looser.
And so the way to apply master
theorem in this case is say,
well, at least f of
n is upper bounded.
It looks like this.
So the best that I can do
is to replace this guy also
with an upper bound.
Yeah.
That's a great question.
AUDIENCE: So the
reason you chose
two is that [INAUDIBLE]
construction of the math
is similar to [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
You got to kind of stand back
and squint at it a little bit,
make sure that it fits.
But certainly, it's the case
that the other two parts
of this theorem don't apply.
So we might as well try
to squeeze this part
into the right form.
All right.
So let's do the tree
version of this.
And then I think
what we're going
to do is skip part three
for now of this problem
because it's mostly a fun
kind of vectorial problem
rather than something
that actually
is going to help your
understanding of algorithms.
And then if we have time at
the end, we'll come back to it.
OK.
All right.
So that was the easy way
to solve the problem.
Now let's do the painful
one where we draw the tree.
I shouldn't say
that because I think
it's something we want
to encourage-- the more
enlightening version, yeah?
So now at the top of my
tree, I do n to the 3/2 work.
And now how many children
does this guy have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Careful.
You have 1 in 2
chances, either 8 or 4.
8, right?
So the outer coefficient
is the number of children
because it's like the number of
function calls you make, right?
That's the way to
think about it, right?
So there's eight of these guys.
OK.
And each one of these guys--
I'm only going to do
one level of these.
Wait, that should
not be connected--
does how much work?
Well, remember that it's
divided by 4 here, right?
So it looks like n/4 to the 3/2.
That make sense, how we got this
picture from our recurrence?
Let me switch to
another piece of chalk.
OK.
Right.
So in other words, if I
look at level l of my tree,
assuming we're going to
index from 0 at the top,
how many nodes are in level l?
Remember, it branches
by 8 each time.
So it has 8 to the l nodes.
Yeah.
And how much work does each do?
Well, in each level,
I divide by 4, right?
So this is going to look like n
times 1/4 to the l to the 3/2.
Right.
Where am I?
There we are.
So that's n times
4 to the minus l.
That's fancy notation for
1/4 to the l to the 3/2.
Notice that this is
exactly the same pattern
as the previous problem.
I'm just plugging in
some different constants.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about the diagram.
If you have a really
large a and you're
trying to do the
recursion tree method,
is this type of work OK
with where you have--
PROFESSOR: If I were grading
your papers, it would be.
But you should probably
check with your TAs on Piazza
on that one.
AUDIENCE: All right.
PROFESSOR: But I've
learned my license.
I'm not sure you guys have yet.
And also, I am not
sure I have, either.
All right, folks.
So now we need to do our total
amount of work here, right?
So how many levels are
there in our tree here?
Well, the amount of data
divides by 4 each time.
And when the amount of data
is 1, then I'm done, right?
So the total number of levels
is equal to the log base 4 of n.
The basic thing to get right
in this problem is just where
there should be 4's and
where there should be 8's.
OK.
So now what am I going to do?
Well, again, as our colleague
in the back points out,
we only have big O. So we can
only upper bound our work.
But our work in the tree
is less than or equal to--
really, there's
a proportion here
because this is just
up to a multiple.
I guess that's
why, in the notes,
they put a little c in
front, which I can do.
Let's do c like that.
Well, we're going to have
the sum from l equals 0
to log base 4 of n of exactly
the quantity, this guy.
Multiply it by the number
of nodes in the row.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is the reason
why you made this work
an inequality because of the--
PROFESSOR: Because of the
big O. That's exactly right.
Yeah.
OK.
All right.
So what do I get here?
Well, let's write it out
the big ugly way first.
So this is n times
4 to the minus l.
This is to the 3/2.
And then this is
multiplied by 8 to the l.
But whoever designed this
problem was really sneaky,
right?
So what's 4 to the
minus l to the 3/2?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: 8 to the minus l.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this is
exactly 8 to the minus l
if we work through all of
your exponent arithmetic.
Yeah.
Why does that matter?
Well, it exactly cancels
this 8 to the l term here.
This is actually exactly what
case two in master theorem
is trying to capture.
So this whole thing is equal
to, really, just n to the 3/2
from l equals 0 to
the log base 4 of n.
All these constants go away.
Isn't that beautiful?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Quick question
about the tree again.
PROFESSOR: No problem.
Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: So do people ever
use these for optimization
in terms of trying to
write a better algorithm,
trying to minimize
the work per level?
Yeah, I'm just curious if
that's an application that's--
PROFESSOR: Sure, I guess so.
I mean, this is
somehow a visualization
of how your algorithm is
making function costs, right?
So every node here kind
of looks like a call
to your piece of code.
So every time you make a new
one, it's like making a call.
And then the divide here is
kind of like how much data
goes into that function call.
So I think this is a useful
way to kind of visualize
what's going on
inside of your code.
And then if you're trying
to optimize your code,
you're trying to basically
reduce the number of nodes
and/or the amount of work
that each node does, right?
Yeah.
So this is just a nice
way to kind of visualize
what's going on in a
recursive algorithm.
Yeah.
Great question.
All right.
So here's a really nice thing.
Does n to the 3/2 depend on l?
No, right?
So this whole thing is equal
to c times n to the 3/2.
And my colleague in
the back is going
to catch me if I don't make
the off by 1 error here.
So this is log base 4 of n plus
1 because my sum started at 0.
Yeah.
And notice that this is exactly
big O of n to the 3/2 log
n, which agrees with what we
did in a much more easy case
with the master theorem.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if I'm
doing the exact bound,
can we say that it's theta
of n to the [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Oh, great question.
This is where this notation
is going to be misleading.
This expression in a vacuum
is theta of this value.
But the reason
that I wrote big O
is because I only have an
inequality all the way up here.
So if I'm worried about
bounding this work,
there's no reason to
write a theta there
because it's just telling me
some kind of intermediate piece
of information.
Yeah.
OK, fabulous.
So yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the
base of the log matter?
PROFESSOR: Does the
Ah.
This is a nice formula here.
So remember that log base
b of a is the same as log a
over log b, if I got that right.
Yeah.
So the base of the log
when it comes to big O
doesn't matter because
it's a constant factor.
Yeah.
OK.
So that's part two
of this problem.
Part three is a
little bit annoying
because it has two
branches in it.
I wrote out a careful solution.
It does not apply
the master theorem
because it's irrelevant,
at least the version
that we know in this class.
So we're going to kind
of skip that for now
because I don't
think it's terribly
relevant to most
of the algorithms
that we'll see in 6.006.
But we'll come back
to it if we have time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can we make that
a lower bound and an upper
bound using master theorem,
knowing that T of n/4
is smaller than T of n/3?
PROFESSOR: I'm going to
refer you to the solutions
rather than talking about
that problem right now.
Yeah.
OK, cool.
All right.
So that's how you apply
master theorem, which
is mildly painful.
The good news is the rest of
this problem set, actually,
I consider to be much easier
than the first one, which
is why I think it's OK to
spend a little bit extra time
here because I think this stuff
is confusing to get right.
Mostly for me, and hopefully
I've conveyed my confusion
to the rest of you.
OK.
So let's erase this.
And while we're doing that,
why don't you guys all
give problem number two a read?
So one of the big skills that
we need to cover in 6.83--
not 6.837, 6.006 and 6.837, but
I'm not quite as evil about it
in that class--
is as follows, which
is you read a problem.
And for some reason,
your instructors
have some sick sense of humor.
And they encode it in this
totally weird, goofy language
which somehow, to
a theoretician,
makes your problem
feel more practical.
So in any event, when you
read all of this paragraph,
the very first skill that you
have to do is to figure out,
OK, like, this is cute notation,
and it's about Infinity Stones.
And if I watch Star
Wars or whatever,
I would know what that meant.
But in any event,
what really matters
is understanding, OK,
but algorithmically,
what are they asking?
Yeah.
So I'm going to try and
talk about this problem
as I erase the board.
So I believe, what, like, Mickey
Mouse or whatever has a bunch,
has some planet that
he's looking for.
I'm going to open
the problem now.
Right, she's a super
villain on a quest.
She's looking for a
stone on a planet,
and the planet has some index k.
And unfortunately for
us, the number of planets
is quite large.
It's infinity, in fact, because
it's the Infinity Stone.
Or, sorry, did I say that?
I think it's the Infinity
Phone or something.
I forget.
But in any event, the
only thing that you
can do when you land on a
planet is ask an oracle,
is the index of my
planet bigger or smaller
than the index of the planet
that I'm standing on, right?
And then the question
is in log k time where
k is the index of the planet.
Notice that's already a
little weird because it's
not the size of
your data, quite.
Can you find the planet?
Now, what does this
kind of problem--
like, what is it screaming
out for you to use?
You see a log k.
You're looking for something.
AUDIENCE: Bisection.
PROFESSOR: Bisection, right?
AUDIENCE: Binary search.
PROFESSOR: Or binary search.
That's absolutely right.
Those are both great answers.
But there's a bit
of a problem, which
is that the number of
planets is unbounded.
We don't know how
many planets there
are in this little universe
that problem 1.2 sets up.
Yeah.
So our intuition is that we
want to use binary search.
But in order to
do binary search,
I need to have a left- and a
right-hand side and divide,
and I have no right-hand side.
So what can I do?
How's a supervillain
to solve this problem?
Well, remember that each planet
has an oracle on it telling me.
Is there something to
my left or my right?
Yeah.
So I could start at
planet number one,
and I could just start walking
from planet one to planet two
to planet three, planet four,
and asking, am I there yet?
Am I there yet?
How much time is
that going to take?
AUDIENCE: Infinite, eventually.
PROFESSOR: Actually, it
won't take infinite time.
I caught you.
How much time will it take?
When will I stop?
When I hit planet k, right,
because I know that planet k
is out there somewhere.
The truth is out there.
And when I find it and
I step on it, I stop.
And I took exactly k
steps, maybe k minus 1,
depending on how you count.
But we need a log k algorithm.
Yeah.
So what can I do?
AUDIENCE: You start at some k,
and then if it's to your right,
you multiply by another k?
PROFESSOR: Multiply
by another k.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
essentially perceived
by another k planets.
So it's like you're
at index k squared.
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
Hmm.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you
go from i to i squared?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
you got the right--
you're in the right
church, wrong pew here.
So the basic intuition
here is that stepping
one planet at a time
doesn't step fast enough.
If you work out the
details on that one,
you're going to find
that you'll end up
with a runtime that still goes
a little bit too quickly in k
here.
In some sense, if you
were to reverse engineer
this problem, which isn't really
a great way to problem set,
you really do expect
there to be powers of 2
in every step of your algorithm.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
do the binary search
and start in the
middle and then ask
the oracle if it's higher or
lower and then [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: It's the
right intuition.
But I have a philosophical
question for you,
which is, what is the middle
of an infinite set of planets?
AUDIENCE: Infinite.
PROFESSOR: Infinite, exactly.
It's a problem.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We could use--
and I don't know who it
was back there who was
suggesting doing i squareds--
except for doing i squared,
replace it with 2 to the i.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
That's a great intuition.
So let's formalize
that a little bit,
which is like, I could
do binary search if I
had a right-hand side.
I have a left-hand
side because it's 1.
So what I'm going
to do, I'm going
to keep trying right-hand sides.
And the oracle is
going to tell me,
is this a valid
right-hand side, right,
because the oracle
is telling me,
is there a planet to my left?
Yeah.
So here's what I'm going to do.
Again, I don't like the index i.
In the official
solution, there's an i.
But I'm going to use the
letter m because I can--
which is the following.
I'm going to visit--
I hate teaching.
No, that's not true.
I like teaching.
I just don't like chalk.
I'm going to visit
planet 2 to the m
for each m starting
with m equals 0
and essentially until--
remember that k is the index
of the planet I'm looking for.
So eventually, I'm going to
reach the point where k is less
than or equal to 2 to the m.
And I know that I
can query my oracle,
and they're going to tell
me when that's the case.
So how much time does this take?
So I'm going to try planet
1 and then planet 2 and then
planet 4 and then 8 and
16 all the way up until k.
AUDIENCE: Log k.
PROFESSOR: So it's going
to take log k time.
AUDIENCE: Can't you also
have a stronger or lower
bound now to the m minus 1?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's sort of right.
Right, so eventually,
what's going
to happen when you stop here
is that 2 to the m minus 1
is going to be less
than or equal to k.
This one equals the 2
to the m because this
is the condition for stopping.
This is a condition
for not stopping.
So when you stop k, this
little sandwich is true.
Yeah.
So if I take the log,
essentially, what I've shown
is that I've taken,
right-- because m
is the number of steps in
this part of my algorithm.
So if I take the log,
I'm going to find
that I took log k steps.
Yeah, nods, acknowledgment.
Yeah.
OK.
And then, well, now I have an
upper bound and a lower bound.
So now what can I do?
AUDIENCE: Binary search.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Now I can binary search.
And that also takes log k time.
AUDIENCE: Is it 2 times
log k [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
Oops.
So now I have step two
is also binary search.
And it's also a log k time,
and our problem is solved.
So problem number
two is not so hard.
Is everybody with me?
Any questions about that one?
That's a quick one.
OK.
Now, problem three really spoke
to me as a computer graphics
professor.
Right.
So now I am running Fadobe.
I collaborate a lot
with Fadobe Fresearch.
Right.
So Fadobe is trying to
make a piece of software
for image editing.
And what does my
piece of software do?
Well, my image, or
I guess my document,
consists of a bunch
of images that
are overlaid with one another.
OK.
And essentially,
what's happening inside
of the software is I want to
keep all the images in order
from top to bottom,
OK, because when I
render my photo, what do I do?
I render the bottom one
and then the next one
and so on and just layer
them on top of each other,
like if you ever played
with PowerPoint or Photoshop
or I guess whatever fake
name they're giving here.
That's a pretty common user
interface to encounter.
And so what they've
asked you to do
is to come up with
essentially a data structure.
And your data structure
has to support
a few different operations.
In particular, you have to
be able to make a document,
import an image and then
stick it on top, display,
which returns all the IDs in the
order that you've stored them.
And then there's
the real kicker,
which is that you need to be
able to take one of the layers
and stick it
underneath another one.
But you have to do
that in log n time.
It's that "but" that
makes this whole problem
kind of a pain in the tuchus.
Yeah.
Right.
So again, here our operations.
We've got to make an empty doc.
This is supposed to
take order 1 time.
We're going to import,
which adds an x on top,
and that this should
take order n time.
Notice that this is already
a little suspicious.
If I were trying to
psychologically diagnose
my professors, I would look
at this order n with some--
like, with a raised eyebrow,
because probably what would you
have in mind if you're talking
about stacks of photographs?
It would be a stack or a
queue or some data structure
like that.
But then insertion would
be like order 1 time.
So there's clearly something
a little more complicated
going on.
OK.
What's number three is display.
This has to happen
in order n time.
This one kind of
makes sense, right,
because in order to
display n things,
you kind of expect to
take at least n time.
And then finally, we
have to move below.
And this has to take
order log n time.
And this is going to be the
kicker, right, because we
really--
this is somehow not totally
obvious from the way
that we set up our problem.
So everybody understand
the problem setup so far?
We just keep adding
objects with IDs,
and we need to be able
to insert them on the top
and then kind of reorder them.
And the problem has given
you runtime for each
of these different operations.
OK.
Right.
So here's the thing.
There's kind of a sequence
aspect to our problem and kind
of a set aspect to our problem.
Does that make sense?
The sequence aspect
to our problem
is that we're going to have
to display stuff in order n
time, right?
We've got to iterate over our
whole list, put stuff on top,
and so on.
And the set aspect
is that we'd like
to move stuff on top of
each other in log n time.
And the reason that I say that
this is somehow set aspect
is that I need to be able to put
any x underneath any y, which
means that I need to be able to
quickly find what layer the x
and the y is in.
Any ideas how we can
solve this problem?
How about from some folks
I haven't heard from yet?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
a really great idea.
So maybe I'm going to
maintain-- so remember,
we've talked about--
let's see.
In my lecture two
lectures ago, we
kind of thought of a sorted
list as a set data structure.
So yeah, that's a fabulous idea.
Why don't we, for the
set part of our problem--
we're going to store in
particular a sorted array of--
and for now, let's think of
it like a sorted array of x's.
And so this is going to be able
to help us answer questions
like, is this ID in my
set of images or not?
But there's also going to be
a second part of my problem,
which is in addition
to that, I need
to be able to keep a
different ordering other
than being just ordered by
x, which is the ordering
that they're being drawn
on the screen, right?
That's different than the
ordering of their IDs.
So for that--
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
We're going to be building a
sorted array with nothing in it
and it's going to be
O of n log n time.
But that's undefined.
So can we build a sorted
array with nothing in it?
PROFESSOR: Hmm.
OK.
No, I'm not sure I quite follow.
AUDIENCE: It's building
an empty sorted array
O of n log n time, which
is O of 0 log 0 time.
And log 0 time [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Empty sorted array?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, building
an empty anything
that takes 1 time.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
All right.
So in addition to this,
we have a sequence aspect
of our problem.
And for that, maybe we'll
use a linked list, right?
That's a pretty reasonable
sequence data structure.
And in fact, let's
think for a second.
Now, we're going to need this
move below operation, right?
So our linked list is
going to store the order
of the images in our document.
In order to move something
below something else,
we're going to have to splice
an image in between two
other guys.
So for convenience, maybe
we have a doubly-linked list
so that we can move
backward and forward so
that we can insert stuff.
Yeah.
So we'll have a
doubly-linked list.
OK.
Right.
So let's start
solving our problem
and then thinking
about where things
are going to go wrong
with our setup here.
So first of all, I
don't think we really
have to write
anything for part one
because making an empty anything
is a pretty easy algorithm.
On your homework, of course, you
should write that and tell us
that it takes order 1 time.
Now, how about
importing an object?
Remember, that puts it on
the top of our linked list.
And we have to insert it
into our sorted array, right?
So when we do that, our insert
algorithm is super simple,
right?
We're going to add x to the set,
which we talked about in class
for a sorted array.
How long does this take for a
sorted array to add something?
AUDIENCE: Order n time.
PROFESSOR: Exactly,
order n time.
But that's actually
OK because that's
our criterion for number two.
Yeah.
And in addition
to that, we'll put
x on the top of the
linked list, right?
That's order 1 time.
That's easy.
I'm adding space
because we're going
to see that we made
a slight mistake
and that we're going to need to
modify our algorithm a tiny bit
to solve this problem.
OK, so how do we display?
I think that's the
simplest one, right?
I'm just going to iterate
over the entire linked list
and just, one by one, output
the order because, remember,
the whole point
of the linked list
is to keep track of all
of our documents in order.
So display, all you have to do
is loop over the linked list.
OK.
And the real kicker is
the last part, right,
which is how do you
move something below?
So let's think for a minute.
What's moving below
going to entail?
So is it going to
affect the set of keys
that are in my document?
No, actually, right?
It's just changing
their ordering,
but both of those keys
are already there.
Yeah.
So the only thing
it's going to do
is effect where they
are in the sequence.
But there's something
really, really annoying.
How do I find something
in this sequence?
Let's say that I tell
you that document 75 has
to move below document 352.
Well, so far in
my data structure,
what's my only option?
Does the set tell me
anything about where
stuff is in the linked list?
No.
So how much time is it going
to take for me to find a key?
AUDIENCE: Order n.
PROFESSOR: Order n,
right, because I've
got to loop over this
whole linked list
and find the item
that I'm missing.
Is that allowed?
No, the problem
tells me that I have
to do this in order log n time.
So somehow in our head,
we should be thinking,
OK, well, we want to
kind of use this set here
to help us find stuff in
the doubly-linked list.
Does that make sense,
that intuition?
So here's how we're
going to do it.
Actually, before I
do that, any ideas?
How can we solve that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Maybe the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
a fabulous idea.
So here's what I'm going to do.
Remember that when
we make a set,
we don't just have
to sort the keys.
We can attach data to our keys.
Yeah.
And in particular, I am going to
attach a pointer into my linked
list.
Really sneaky answer.
So let's say that I have--
let's do a quick example.
So let's say that
I have my documents
are 1, 5, 3, 2,
and 7, like that.
So my linked list is
going to be real simple.
It's doubly linked.
See, there's two arrows
here, just like that, right?
And now my sorted array is going
to store all the keys in order.
Let's see if I can
do this with me.
1, 2, 3, 5, 7, right?
So this is my linked list.
And here's my sorted array
is going to be 1, 2, 3, 5, 7.
But then what I'm going to
attach to each of these guys
is a pointer to the element
of the linked list, right?
So he is going to additionally
contain an arrow here.
The 2 will contain
an arrow there.
The 3 will contain
The 5-- this is ugly, I'm sorry.
Now, here's the thing.
Let's say that I
remove this 3 here.
Does that actually
affect 7's pointer?
No, right?
So these pointers
remain valid even if I
edit other parts of the list.
Really sneaky trick.
OK.
So that is going
to be our solution
to this problem is to store not
just the sorted array of x's
but x's and pointers.
So now we have to modify
a tiny bit, right?
And now what can we do
to move something below?
Well, it's going to happen in
sort of three steps, right?
So our first step,
well, we've got to first
find keys x and y, right?
So we're going to find x,
vx, and y, vy in the set.
How long does this take?
Now we can do it in
binary search, right?
Exactly.
So this is O, like that.
And now what's my next step?
Well, remember, the
move below operator
sort of removes x from where it
currently is and then puts it
underneath y, right?
And both of those are like
linked list editing operations,
right?
So I'm going to kind of--
if I have a linked list,
like 1, 2, 3, 4, right,
and let's say I
want to erase the 2,
I think you guys have
all coded this up
at some point in your lives.
Then what I'll do is add
links like that, which
I can do because
I can move forward
and backward in the list, right?
And similarly, if I
want to add something,
then I'll erase the
links, put it in there,
and update the links.
How much time does that take?
That's just order 1
time, right, because now
that I have the pointers
to these two locations,
I'm just doing a lot of
rewiring in my linked list.
But it's all kind
of local stuff.
If you're coding in C, this is
where your memory leak happens,
and your company gets hacked.
OK.
Right, so that is what
we're going to do next
is update the linked list.
And that takes order 1 time.
On your homework, if you're
writing out your answer,
you should have an answer closer
to what I've written on my page
than the two words that I've
written on the board here.
And then finally,
in step three--
well, actually, there is no step
three that I've written here.
Sorry.
There's actually two parts
to updating the linked list,
right?
One is to remove
the old x position
and then insert in the
proper position, right?
And when I do that, my
whole update happened.
Notice that there's
something kind
of interesting about this move
below operation, which is that,
did I actually edit
the set at all?
No, right?
That kind of makes sense
because the set is just
a set of keys in my document.
And just by changing
the ordering,
it doesn't affect
what's in my document.
So somehow, it's a sanity
check that that works out.
So this entire algorithm
takes how long?
Well, there's order log n.
There's order 1.
And there's another order 1.
So the whole thing is log n.
And life is good for
our problem here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how we can put
such pointers in real life?
PROFESSOR: How do we
input such point--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] like
a set with pointers in it
in real life?
PROFESSOR: Got it.
So I only know the
C++ version of this.
I'm going to get it
wrong for Python.
But I'm not sure that I quite
understand the question.
So it's just like pointers
anywhere else in real life.
So I guess in
Python, what you'll
do is you'll create
a new, right-- as you
add these guys to
your set, you'll
create a new object here.
And in addition to
that, you're going
to create a new vx that
you add to the linked list.
And the pointer is just an
address in memory, right?
So essentially,
what you'll store--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] linked
list nodes are the pointers.
PROFESSOR: The
linked list nodes are
pairs, a pair of an x value
and a-- well, oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah, actually, I
guess that's right.
No.
The linked list just contains
a long list of x's, right?
But they don't have to
be in contiguous memory.
That's the only difference.
So you make them one
linked list item a time.
But it's just like constructing
any other linked list.
Yeah.
In fact, there's
pseudocode in the solutions
that are distributed.
So you can take a look there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
speaking of which,
for implementing these
database operations,
can we pseudocode the
algorithms for them?
PROFESSOR: I think the official
answer is no, that you really
are supposed to write out in
words what your thing is doing.
Now, there's a weird
gray area, of course,
which is that the words
that you write out
are going to look an
awful lot like pseudocode.
But you should make an
effort to try and write it
out a little bit in paragraph
form, be descriptive about it.
This is a good skill to learn.
At the beginning
of this course, I
think it'll feel a little
pedantic at points.
And that's good
because it should,
and you should deal with it.
Yeah.
But really, try and
write things out
in a way that captures
your logic rather than just
Python code.
Yeah.
Cool.
All right.
So let's see.
We've got approximately
17 minutes
left in class, which is
approximately 1/8 of the time
it took me to figure out the
solution to this last homework
problem.
But we'll get started.
And I've written out a careful
answer because essentially,
in problem four, I
found myself getting
stuck in a few little details.
And so I figured the
way that I write out
my little hand-scribbled
chicken scratch
answer online was to
just basically give you
an internal dialogue
of my brain and how
I went about solving
these things and all
the stupid missteps that I made.
Yeah.
Because I think that's
actually quite valuable.
Essentially, it's often you
see in these problems sessions
just like, oh, here's a problem.
Here's the answer.
Here's a problem.
But the reality is
even your professor,
especially because he's used
to thinking about rendering,
occasionally gets confused
about these algorithms
problems, especially when
they're frankly written
in a bit of a confusing way.
And I heard some war stories
about this problem actually
being on the homework.
Apparently, I'm in good company.
So let's take a look at this
last homework problem, 1-4.
So this is on brick blowing.
And this is a great exercise
in taking a problem that
is described in really long,
nasty, useless language
and then extracting the
two words that matter.
By the way, I'm making
a joke about that.
I can tell you that about
82% of my time as a professor
is spent with
people from industry
visiting my office with
exactly this kind of scenario
where it has a really
complicated thing.
They've been thinking
about their construction
problem for years, and they have
all these details and tables
and flow charts.
And then it turns out that
their problem can be captured
in about two sentences.
So it's a good skill
to have and one
that can get you a lot
of money as a consultant.
So it's one that's worth
practicing in this class
even if we're doing it
for Porkland with a wolf
that blows only to the east.
OK.
So what's going on
in this problem?
There's a wolf, and the
wolf can blow on houses.
But for some reason, the wolf
likes to blow to the right.
And to make matters even
more complicated, whoever
wrote this problem
occasionally ordered things
from east to west
and other times
ordered them from west to east.
If I were your instructor
at the time, that,
I would have at least gotten
rid of because that's just mean.
But in any event,
I believe the story
goes as the apocryphal
house-blowing pork wolf
story that we all know and
love from our childhood
is there's a row of
houses, each of which
has a different
number of bricks.
Yeah.
And now there's a wind which
is blowing from west to east.
I remember all this because I
was staring at it this morning
in my office.
And essentially, the wolf, being
the big, bad wolf that he is,
says, aha, if I, too,
blow from west to east,
I can knock over more
houses more efficiently
because the wind is helping me.
You don't want to
blow into the wind.
You get your spit in your face.
OK, so the wolf does that.
And then what happens is that
the wolf not only knocks down
the house upon
which the wolf blows
but also all the houses to
the east of that house that
have fewer bricks.
Why, you might ask?
I don't know, because whoever
wrote this problem was
being a goofball.
But that's the basic
setup of this problem.
And you can see that,
essentially, this
is just a long, convoluted
way of describing something
pretty straightforward.
And so at the end of
the day, the wolf,
being kind of an
adversarial wolf,
wants to blow down as
many bricks as possible.
And we are providing the wolf
with the analytical tools
needed to do so.
Yeah.
So in case you didn't think
we covered anything practical
in 6.006, now you know
that we actually are doing
state-of-the-art wolf
brick-blowing pig analysis.
OK.
Right.
So let's do an example because
this is weirdly complicated.
So in the first
part of the problem,
it asks you to just
do an example out.
And I think if I were
psychologically diagnosing
the person who wrote this
problem, probably the reason is
that they stood
back, and they said,
nobody's going to understand
this unless I force
them to do one example by hand.
Right?
And so the basic
problem is asking,
I could choose to
blow on each house.
Which one should I choose
to cause the most damage?
Or in fact, they actually ask
a slightly different problem,
which is if I were to blow on
each house, how much damage
would I cause?
OK, so let's step
through the problem.
So they give you an example, a
set of numbers, 34, 57, 70, 19,
48, 2.
Actually, let's just stop there.
I don't think there's
any reason to do
a list of a million numbers
like in the problem.
That was just like, the
more times you do it,
the more you convince
yourself how useless 6.006 is.
OK.
Right.
So how much damage does blowing
on house number one cause?
Well, let's make a little table.
So if I blow on house
number one, just by default,
house number one falls.
I'll pull an x there,
meaning I blew it over.
And then the rule is
any house to the right
which has fewer bricks--
the physics of this
problem drives me nuts.
I thought about it
for quite a long time,
and I can't think of a wind
that actually has this property.
But any house that has fewer
bricks and is to the east
also gets blown down.
So 57 does not, right?
That's bigger than 34.
Similarly for 70.
Aha, the 19 goes with the wind.
48's bigger, and
the 2 goes, right?
So the element number one of
my array would be 3, right?
Three things get blown over.
OK, for the next guy, right?
So the 57 gets blown over.
It does not blow over the
34 because my wolf only
knows how to blow to the right.
Uh.
So it does not blow over the 70.
It does blow over the 19.
It does blow over the 48.
It does, right?
So here, there'd be a 4.
These numbers do not match
the ones in the notes
because this is a shorter list
of numbers, I should point out.
OK, let's do one
more, and then we're
going to stop because this
is laborious and boring.
So the 70 blows over everything.
Yeah.
But only everything to its
right because, as we all know,
wolves only blow to the--
OK, I'll shut up.
So there's four things
that get blown over here.
But you guys get
the point, right?
And so essentially,
this problem is
asking you to fill
in arrays that look
like this for your problem.
Everybody on board
with the problem?
Now, notice that just by
virtue of doing this example,
let's think about
this abstractly
because I think this
is a problem that's
just coded in so many words
and made-up weird TA garbage.
But at the end of
the day, this problem
as an algorithmic
problem is not so bad.
Essentially, what I'm asking
you to do is I look at that 57,
and I look to the right,
and I count how many
things are smaller than 57.
And I add 1 to it.
And that's the
number that should go
in that element in the array.
So notice that those
three paragraphs,
that's what they're
communicating.
You didn't need wolves
blowing and winds
and trees and houses and Dorothy
and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
Right.
So at the end of the day, that's
the problem we can think about.
And we no longer have to think
about Porkland ever again.
OK.
So maybe in the
remaining 10 minutes
here, I think we can
feasibly do part b.
And then part c is an
extension of part b.
I got myself confused on part
c, so the handwritten solutions
have an incorrect answer,
and then an oops, and then
a correct answer in it.
So you can see where
my logic went wrong.
To be fair, I already
knew the full answer
and wrote out both because
I thought that was useful.
OK.
So in case our problem
wasn't contrived enough,
we're going to add a little
bit of condition to it.
And then what we're
going to see in part c
is that's somehow a stepping
stone toward solving the bigger
problem.
So in part c, they say
that a house in Porkland
is special if it has
one of two properties.
Either it has no
easterly neighbor,
meaning it's just
the rightmost house,
or its adjacent
neighbor to the east
contains at least as
many bricks as it does.
Right.
So what does that mean in
terms of this list of numbers?
Which one of these
guys is special?
So the easterly guy is special.
We just know that by
default. And other
than that, this
special property is
saying that the guy
immediately to the right
has a bigger number or at least
equal to or larger to the one
right before it.
Yeah.
So 57 is bigger than 34,
so this guy is special.
By the way, the
problem doesn't ask
you to do this as an example.
But I totally would if
I were solving this.
Yeah.
70 is bigger than
57, so it's special.
19 is smaller than 70,
so it's not special.
I'm sorry.
40 is bigger than 19.
And I guess 2 is special just
because things on the right
are special.
OK, so do we all
get the definition?
Fabulous.
So in this problem, now what
we're given is that I guess,
what, our evil wolf takes
a walk down the block
and takes a look at--
counts the number of
bricks at each house.
And he or she makes
an observation,
which is that all but
one house is special.
Now, let's think
about what that means.
Let's think about the
structure of our array.
So what happens as I
walk along my right?
If a house is special, what do
I know about the next house?
AUDIENCE: It won't get blown if
you blow a special house down.
PROFESSOR: That's
true, but we're already
solving the problem there.
Let's think qualitatively for
a second, like just in terms
of the number of bricks, right?
I'm walking down the street.
I'm looking.
And the number of
bricks increases
until I get to the one
house that isn't special.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And then it
decreases, potentially,
or it's the last one.
And then it starts
increasing again.
Yeah.
So in other words,
my array kind of
looks like the following,
which is that it basically
has two different pieces
that are both sorted.
Yeah.
That's what this long
paragraph is saying.
It's saying suppose
that the list of houses
is sorted except for one thing.
Yeah.
That's how you
could have said it.
OK, so here's an example.
So maybe we have 1, 2, 3, 4, and
then, I don't know, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So all of these is special
with the exception of this guy,
sadly for him.
And so there's kind of
a little dividing line
that happens, to the left
of which, it's sorted,
and to the right.
Yeah.
OK, and then the
question is, can we
predict the damage
for each house
based on this information?
So I want as output to my
code an array that says,
this guy causes so much damage,
and so on.
And I want to get
it in order n time.
Let's think for a second.
So how are we going to do that?
So order n time
means that I can't
afford to do sorting and all
that kind of fancy stuff.
So basically, all I can do is
walk up and down the array.
So we should think a bit about,
what's special about special--
oy vey.
What's special about
this configuration
that we wouldn't normally have?
AUDIENCE: Anything before the
non-special node should have
the same--
or I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
AUDIENCE: Everything
after the non-special node
causes only one damage.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so let's
think about this carefully.
I think that's right, but
I'm bad at parsing sentences.
Remember that I always
blow to the right,
and I only blow short stuff.
So if I blow on
this 2 here, will
anything before that vertical
line ever get blown over?
No, because by property
of being special,
we know that the
list is increasing.
But it has to decrease
to blow something over.
That make sense?
So for each one of these guys,
the only stuff we can blow
is in the second array.
Does that make sense?
So we made an observation.
Notice that it is
special to the structure
that we gave to our problem.
Yeah.
And moreover, so in both
parts of this problem,
we're going to look at
two parts of an array
and then merge them
together in a smart way.
Let's look on the
right-hand side.
Does any of these things--
if I blow on any
of these houses,
what's the damage that I do?
1.
You see that?
Because this is an increasing
list, I only blow to the right,
and it has to get shorter.
Yeah.
So if I want partial credit
on my homework problem--
probably very little partial
credit, but spiritually,
it's half of your credit--
we know the second half of my
array is just a bunch of 1's.
Incidentally, one detail which
I bet would get a minus 1
on your homework,
we didn't tell you
that-- all we told you
is that there existed
one house that wasn't
special, but we
didn't tell you which one.
But notice that I can find
it in order n time, right?
I can just walk along my
array and find the first place
where it decreases, and
that's a special house.
So I can kind of assume that
I know where this line is.
That's kosher.
So then the only question is,
how do I fill in my array here?
How do I count--
and so let's think about
this mathematically
because porks and blowing and
stuff is kind of confusing.
So let's think about it
in terms of this array.
Essentially, what
am I trying to do?
So for this 2,
I'm trying to look
in the second half of my array
and find all the numbers here
that are less than 2, right?
That's essentially what this
problem is asking you to do.
You see that?
OK.
I'm going to make
one-- so here's
a simple kind of n
squared algorithm, right,
which is I could iterate
over every item here
and just loop over here and
count the number of things
that are less than that, right?
That's a double for loop, each
of which could be up to n.
So that's n squared.
That's against the rules.
Can't do it.
So we need one more
additional observation.
OK.
Let's think about
this for a second.
Let's say I'm the wolf,
the pork-blowing wolf.
And I walk from one
house to the next.
And I keep track of what
houses get blown over here.
Now, what happens?
As I walk from one house to
the next on the left-hand side,
they're only getting
taller, right?
That's what it
means to be special.
So the houses that get blown
over here, the set of those
only grows larger.
Does that make sense?
Because as these
guys get taller,
more stuff falls over
on the right-hand side.
It's like a total goofball
talking about this problem.
Moreover, these guys
are in sorted order.
Yeah.
So what's going to
end up happening
is that, always, there's
just some interval of houses
that gets knocked over.
So for example, the 4 blows
over the 2 and the 3, I guess.
Notice that that always
starts on the left-hand side.
And that's because
these guys are sorted.
The 3 just blows
over the 2, which
is kind of a subset of the 4.
This isn't a great example
because those first two
guys don't blow over anything.
That make sense?
Any ideas?
How could I use that observation
to make an order n algorithm
for counting blowiness damage?
I've heard a lot from you.
Let's hear from some of
our other colleagues here.
Another person.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Binary search.
PROFESSOR: Binary search.
Tell me more.
What would I search for?
AUDIENCE: So let's
say you have 4,
and you move by
yourself from the right,
take the index of that, and
then you take the number.
PROFESSOR: It's an
interesting intuition.
And it's, like, 82% right.
So to repeat our colleague's
suggestion, which is a good one
and will make your
code a lot faster--
in fact, in practical
terms, it would probably
be about the same.
It would be I'm going
to move from the left
to the right-hand side
unless there's a very
large neighborhood of pigs.
I'm going to move
across this array.
I'm going to binary
search this other side
and find the first house
that shouldn't get blown over
or something.
And now I know the total number
of things that get blown over.
Now, unfortunately
for you, what's
the runtime of that algorithm?
n log n, right?
Because for every
single guy here,
I incur a binary search
there, which is log n time.
So you're in the
church, wrong pew here.
But there's an observation
we haven't used yet,
which is as I move to the
right, these numbers increase.
Yeah.
So what's going to happen to
the index of the stuff that
gets blown over?
It's always going
to move this way.
Is it ever going to
move to the left?
No.
So there is a term that we
used in two lectures ago, which
is a term I never heard
before, but I kind of like it.
It's called a
two-finger algorithm.
Yeah.
What does the
two-finger algorithm do?
Looks like this.
Two fingers.
Yeah.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to keep my finger on
the right pointing
at the very first thing
that doesn't get blown over.
OK.
So here, right, the 1
doesn't blow over anything.
So it stays here.
I'm going to iterate
to the next guy.
Does the 2 blow over anything?
No, by the way the
problem is written.
Now I'm going to
move this guy here.
Well, now the 3 blows
over the 2 here.
So I'm going to move my right
finger one thing to the right
and move the guy to 4.
The 4 also doesn't
blow over anything,
and then I guess I'm done.
But the basic point
here is that I'm always
going to be incrementing
two different pointers
and moving to the right.
And so what am I going to do?
If I call this finger
i and this finger j,
will i or j ever decrease?
No.
So if my algorithm is looping
over all of these guys
and they only ever touch
each of these indices once,
I'm going to get an
order n technique.
Yeah.
And that's going to be the basic
trick to solving this problem.
Now, I've managed to
talk myself out of time.
But basically, that's it.
So what I'm going to do if
we have 10 extra seconds
is I'm going to initialize.
Essentially, for each i,
I'm going to increment j
until the number of
bricks at j is greater
than the number of bricks at i.
I guess that should be
greater than or equal to.
Right?
And the reason to do that is
that now the number of houses
that get blown over
is just this index
j minus the index of
the first guy, right?
And then I'll increment
i and continue.
That make any sense?
Fabulous.
So I managed by some
miracle to make it
to almost the end
of this problem set
minus one part of one problem.
Of course, that's the hardest
part of the whole problem set.
But there's an
answer written out
where, essentially, now
the question is, can you
do exactly the same algorithm
but I don't give you
this special assumption that it
increases and then decreases?
And it's going to be basically
an extension of this idea,
as we're going to use this plus
a little bit of merge sort.
OK.
So with that, we'll
see you guys next week.
It's always a pleasure.
And yeah, have a lovely weekend.